okay focus crying Oh get over get over
here some at how I know just come in
come here help me right we're helping
each other wrong right just go
underneath Jase it's like you've never
played it but not before dude I played
the if it was a great game RPG maker
ahead babe okay wait say yeah I bet it
okay I know
come here all right would and you help
me up oh I help you up all right
yeah that's pretty simple oh wait wait I
know I don't [ __ ] know just Kasai hey
hey yeah yeah this is our score 42 yeah
I'm gonna to the - to the room adding a
zero at the end of that I think you are
American and not very good in
zero fine whatever
let's go let's go this game is [ __ ]
beautiful I feel like I'm becoming
hipster every minute this is not hipster
this is art oh well I feel like I'm
becoming alright okay you are now a work
of art it seems we just murdered two
balls but let's protect this one let's
make sure he get him up here then okay
good job well I try you're never gonna
be a babies that are in your life oh
okay okay I'm sorry
let's drink no not that one let's bring
this one okay that one yes thank you
Mary Brad are you all right guys oh no
it's not my fault okay wait wait wait
wait come on what you pushed me
no no okay I like how we're equally
stupid all right now we got it let's
pause here for a moment okay oh wow okay
there now jump over here alright I'll go
first
there no luck no hey come on cry you
fine okay good man okay go you [ __ ]
pushed me I did
it's a kid oh oh oh missing all these
points alright oh hi okay we're up here
give me points
no points you know that fact that I'm
gonna get these points what all right
get ready for the points that way is
reports thank you're welcome I'm gonna
get these points you're too short for
those points one day you'll learn if
they don't know that is yes I think I
need you here yeah
there we go I wonder fun you're welcome
I'll need you again huh all right hey
can I jump on you never get a my head
get on my head
jump get on my head jump there we go
you're welcome okay now I'm gonna go oh
yeah you can just go through yep
why do you let me do this before because
we just thought of it
oh [ __ ] Oh get on my head I don't know I
have no in this cry I'm trusting you
right all right okay you go girl
we're good all right make sure to get
the points okay I'm gonna get all the
points getting all the points all the
point
hi I missed some points these balls what
we got it we got to be smart about this
one just drop information like that
sorry
yeah wait I said wrong but I'll check
yes HL over here you take a lefty all
right jump ahead Joe why why why sorry
I'm not gonna get mad at you all right
get them had channeled you three job why
didn't you jump you didn't jump
you didn't you did not jump you are not
a jumper okay I'm gonna come and get my
head man jump jumpy jumpy dude
son of a [ __ ] Jamba Juice is delicious
it is right everywhere it why not I'm
jumpy okay go go don't go go ahead jump
jump jump jump yes
thank you yes wait I got some friends
thank you want you to meet Mari
yeah oh wait wait wait we have some of
these again this why so we can get the
points which points the points what are
you doing get my head now we get the
points which
like into the point let's go yeah we
need to kill them no no we got him we go
alright maybe you're right so what we
gotta do so what we gotta do
it's good so what we have to do is go
across here oh yeah both have to be over
here no I just did it you're telling you
you can maneuver better come on shut up
you can do it let's go okay don't win it
oh don't don't
it's got me cry what do I say I'm trying
I'm saying all right mother break them
off get them on get all the points one
point yes all these points get every
single points okay now you can jump up
here yes do you have Christmas and
Sweden no yes oh that was so cool we're
not even in water we could have gotten
for 20 points
we're doing the Riverdance this is not a
Riverdance I'm digging this okay I think
I need to end it you probably should yes
yeah painted cherry keep doing the balls
okay that's actually a pretty good
cherry yeah yeah I've seen worse feyo
and
whatever I'll see ya bye this has been
great whatever
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]